un job dating pour les 95 salariés de la
société via pâques c'est l'événement
organisé au sein du smart cities campus
le lieu où étaient installées leurs
sites de production aujourd'hui à
l'arrêt suite à la liquidation
judiciaire prononcée en décembre dernier
pour moi c'est la suite logique car je
veux dire on peut être représentants du
personnel mais il faut assurer le
service après vente comme on dit on peut
pas dire c'est noël c'est fini on voit
on passe à autre chose pour moi c'est un
devoir
aujourd'hui heureusement on a fait notre
deuil
il ya pas qu appartient au passé et on
le laisse au passé et puis là on démarre
une nouvelle aventure
on a l'occasion de rencontrer
différentes boîtes différents directeurs
des entreprises pour lesquelles on
n'aurait jamais pensé pouvoir postuler
le smart cities campus le comité
d'entreprise de via paquet la députée
aurore bergé ont organisé cet événement
un élan de solidarité pour le tissu
économique rambolitains l'idée c'est de
faire de cet événement qui dit toujours
un événement évidemment douloureux quand
une entreprise faire mais quand en plus
elle a été si importante pour le
territoire à créer des nouvelles
opportunités et les nouvelles
opportunités
elle existe aussi sur le territoire
c'est un peu le paradoxe c'est qu'on a
un territoire qui est presque en plein
emploi 5% de taux de chômage à peu près
ici mais on a des entreprises qui
cherchent 25 entreprises du sud-yvelines
des grands groupes des pme et des tpe
présent pour trouver de la main d'oeuvre
et rendre possible le reclassement de
ces personnes c'est un profil que l'on
peut trouver notamment chez les ch et
les personnes qui travaillaient chez via
pack donc j'en ai rencontré plusieurs
qui avait qui avait à peu près se
profile à la fin de la journée 15
contrats ont déjà été signés
d'autres salariés ont un deuxième rendez
vous 2 prévu pour approfondir le premier
entretien